it's doing so I definitely am curious
well this is a pretty adult movie this
is definitely rated R have you actually
seen any rated R movies yes I see okay
yeah you go first
I've seen two in there both Seth Rogen
produced or is in one of them
both of them actually yeah I've seen two
sausage party and super bad but that was
yeah they were both in Canada actually
me you watch super bad together and last
day yeah our last day right after the
photo shoot yeah they were they were
really able to watch us in Canada
because the ratings different if
something's rated R I think it was
fourteen eight yeah yeah yeah I saw
parts of super bad I think that's really
funny and I was given permission to
watch super bad with Keith because we
kind of wanted to compare our characters
to some of the characters in super red
it was a work thing yeah sure but my
first actual rate at our movie was
Caddyshack and I wash out my dad that's
just like an OG rated R movie that's a
good one I loved that film
and I'm not sure if you were allowed to
see it yet but when you can he's
actually in it right isn't it that's a
hundred percent um so you okay let's
move on to something else
um I am curious there is you guys have
to do a lot of stuff in this movie what
was the day that you went to set
actually like I don't want to say
nervous but like a little bit like were
you nervous any day with some of the
stuff you were fast I was really nervous
I was just like going for well uh
nervous about my lines yes since it was
a comedy it was really fun I really
couldn't be nervous I was I was
definitely nervous like the first day
cuz I was kind of like the new beyoncé I
mean I've done some other stuff but
nothing like big like this and I was
like really getting nervous because I
kind of wanted to prove myself but then
when I got there that they were just
like Jacob and keeper just so comforting
and they gave me pointers and I I'm so
grateful for that and
more comfortable on the camera than ever
I understand I'm curious
you had to film a kissing scene at if I
was your age filming that I would be
terrified okay fine I was so scared
that was the one where I was the most
nervous on step I was like because my
mom was like you know keep your mouth
dry and I was like I really don't want
to do this at the same time I was like I
felt like he was very important
important for my character to do this
and remember it's only it's it's only
the character yeah take them can't be
kissing Millie like yeah I understand I
would seriously though I would have been
terrified yes straight I'm super scary
yeah so you guys must be on like a group
text
you guys are pregnant no actually me and
Brady together bragging way but we don't
we all have each other and fortnight so
I I don't have any I don't I don't I
used to have you but I and I've never
had you I'm yet to get some card that's
why I'm yeah I'm Mike everyone at the
end of song I got it so basically for
tonight as a thing you guys play
together yeah I haven't really played it
that much but Brady is so good at this
he carries me so much I'm just hiding in
the corner and he's just like building
up doing all the work for me I'm just
like yay Bradley I was like protect the
president
so me and Jacob we were in a lobby with
some my friends and it was like it was
in creative mode so we were playing uh
something called zone wars and they were
all targeting Jake and me cuz me and
Jake we're on team so Jacob Weiss told
Jacob Hyde and we fought every ocean and
then right and then it went it was just
me and Jacob left after we killed
everyone I let him kill me so he got the
win yeah good job Tim NIT foes in the
neither oh yeah I meant for 202 go but I
will say that's very similar to the
characters in the movie ya know what I
mean
if it but in the movie Jacob Jacob would
kill Brady no actually in the movie yeah
you would kill him because he wants to
take the no he would kill you because he
wants to take the wine or racism because
he has a
a paintball gun and I have just some
boards yes like yeah no no it did me
keep taking the one cuz he just like
flipping a bunch of people oh yeah just
pick us up like Lion King style yes
throw us we should be like to see you